SUMMIT
SUMMI
SUMMIT IS ON OR OFF.
>> Sean: AND JOINING US A FOX
NEWS CONTRIBUTOR DANIEL HOFFMAN
IS WITH US.
I LOVE THE WAY THE PRESIDENT
STATES IT.
MISSILES NOT FIRED OVER JAPAN,
GUAM'S NOT IN JEOPARDY, THE
KOREAN PENINSULA IS MORE SAFE
AND HOSTAGES RELEASED, TRUMP
PULLS OUT THEY BEG, NO, NO, NO,
PLEASE, PLEASE.
NO DOWN SIDE AND WE DIDN'T PAY
CASH THIS TIME, DID WE?
>> IT'S QUITE A CONTRAST FROM
WHAT THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
GAVE UP TO GET BERGDAHL BACK
FROM SOME BAD TERRORISTS.
WHAT I'D HIGHLIGHT IN THE
MEETING BETWEEN SECRETARY POMPEO
AND THE FEWER-STAR GENERAL
FORMER HEAD OF MILITARY
INTELLIGENCE AND REFLECTS THE
SERIOUSNESS WITH WHICH KIM
JONG-UN IS APPROACHING THE
SUMMIT.
AND KIM JONG-UN HAS BEEN
TARGETED FOR RESPONSIBLE FOR
KILLING 46 SOUTH KOREAN SAILORS
IN 2010 BUT THIS IS THE HAND
WE'RE DEALT WITH AND PART OF THE
CHALLENGE OF DEALING WITH A
HERMIT KINGDOM AND THE
NEGOTIATIONS THAT WILL HAVE TO
TAKE PLACE WITH UNSAVORY
CHARACTERS.
>> Sean: I LOVE THE FACT THAT
ALL THESE BIG DEVELOPMENTS HAVE
HAPPENED.
THE PRESIDENT HAS GIVEN UP
NOTHING.
I THINK THE FACT THAT THE MEDIA
DOESN'T UNDERSTAND, THIS IS THE
ART OF THE DEAL.
THIS IS HOW YOU NEGOTIATE.
MAYBE IT HAPPENS ON THE 12th.
MAYBE IT DOESN'T.
MAYBE IT TAKES ONE MEETING, TWO
MEETINGS, PLEA
MEETINGS, PLE
MEETINGS, THE
MEETINGS, THRE
MEETINGS, THREE
MEETINGS, THREE M
MEETINGS, THREE MAY
MEETINGS, THREE MAYBE
MEETINGS, THREE MAYBE M
MEETINGS, THREE MAYBE MOR
MEETINGS, THREE MAYBE MORE.
IT'S WORTH IT FOR NOT ON THE
COUNTRY BUT WORLD.
AND SO MUCH PROGRESS I THINK
KRISTIN IS RIGHT, WE DIDN'T
ANTICIPATES SIX MONTHS AGO.
>> I THINK NORTH KOREA TRIED TO
PRACTICE THE ART OF BRINKMANSHIP
AND THE PRESIDENT WALKED AWAY
AND INJURY KOREA CAME BACK WITH
A BELLICOSE MESSAGE INDICATING
THEY WERE SERIOUS IN TALKING TO
US.
IT WILL BE AN EXTRAORDINARILY
COMPLEX SERIES OF NEGOTIATIONS.
RUSSIA IS ALREADY INTERFERING
WITH TALK OF RATCHETING DOWN THE
SANCTIONS WHICH IS NOT HELPFUL
BUT I THINK WE'RE PLAYING OUR
HAND AS AS WELL AS WE POSSIBLY
COULD.
I WOULDN'T EXPECT IMMEDIATE
GRATIFICATION BUT WE'RE SHOWING
THE NORTH KOREANS WE MEAN
BUSINESS AND THE PATTERN WE
FOLLOW SHOWING STRENGTH TO NORTH
KOREA CLEARLY HAS BEEN MORE
EFFECTIVE THAN WHAT WE'VE SEEN
FROM THE PAST TWO DECADES.
>> Sean: AND THE PRESIDENT I
THINK RIGHTLY SO MANAGING
EXPECTATIONS IN TERMS OF WHAT
THE SHOULD EXPECT.
IF IT HAPPENS, OR DOESN'T
MAPPEN.
-- HAPPEN THE BALL WILL BE IN
THEIR COURT AND IT WILL BE ABOUT